every one of the things you can do is
you can conjure up people's fears yes
okay yes so you you're afraid of quite
basic things you I'm afraid of like most
things like anything high-risk I'm
terrified of but those irrational okay
irrational is big spiders cuz but they
actually um I become paralyzed when I
when I have a spider in my room really
yeah I like wish I were tougher than
that but I'm not okay no wall Gruffalo
were you serious when you told us what
your fear is I mean isn't it's a good
fear it's I think it's a founded fear I
think it's a founded fear it is tell us
what it is I have a phobia of being
chased around with poop on a stick it's
there I wouldn't say I'd say we've all
got that fear the girls know what for
that it started when I was a kid was
just weird parenting for some reason
kids thought it was funny to stick a
stick and dog poop and chase each other
around but that scared the crap out of
me
because of the cleanliness problem of it
no spreading germs great of sticks
but now jeremy renner though yours is
brilliantly specific and I think we did
without knowing it I think we probably
all share it we may I don't know I I
didn't have the the fear when I was
younger because we've all we all go
through this but it's when a little
child and I'm the oldest of seven kids
and I got a lot of little Rugrats
running around and these little Roach
and start losing their teeth and they
get a little Wiggly and they like to
show me like this little dagger looping
in and out of their mouth and I look up
the Jimmy want to pull this thing out oh
my god get out of here you're freaking
me out but don't you think that is
really freaky
I use my thumb it just really kind of
gross to me at the cutest little thing
and the planet starts to do like the
creepiest thing on the planet and then I
get out of yours like your tie the
string to my thing to the doorknob make
it out of your creep you're seeing an
animal that's now running around
flipping their little fake their kitty
falling out look we'll have this you
know when you have the dreams your teeth
pull out I don't know what it means
anybody want a means we get bigger and
ones
no bad dream babe
am I the only one that's bad a friend of
mine just had that dream - just a friend
of your right yeah not me what does that
mean I don't know I don't know your
sustain share of money I think I think
that's what the fear of money yeah
Frankie I'm is afraid of my teeth
[ __ ] fall
Joslyn look your fear what are you
afraid of well I was gonna go with
flying but I think I'll go with girls
over 12
I don't know what came over
the last minute of my life I wouldn't
have predicted that was it Mark Ruffalo
you're not gonna believe what he said to
me he was bang on the money
Dora poor don't try and justify do you
know what I've always hated the Hulk
he's [ __ ] make an angry yeah you have
like me when I'm angry ruffle I left
my son said that to me the other day
when he was mad at me
well then you wouldn't like him I always
hated the hoggar Dickie [ __ ] I gave just
told him that he's afraid of girls over
12 for him - that will be okay
child
better folks that are focused it's not
it not easy look at that see inside her
my knowledge okay which was I'm actually
afraid of sperm in places it's not
supposed to be what your forensic
scientists yeah